[Music]
I'm not quick to call somebody racist
and I've never done so before in my
entire life but the things that Vanessa
Warwick has recently done and said have
made me so angry particularly as she has
just been put as a new advisor on the
panel on the property redress scheme I
have to get this off my chest the truth
is as shocking as this is to say this is
the truth there are many landlords in
the UK right now that are discriminating
against tenants and refusing to let
certain people live in their properties
simply because of the color of their
skin and the property redress scheme
having the likes of Vanessa Warwick on
the board of advisors she and others in
position of authority are helping and
assisting landlords with their racist
discrimination right now the last thing
that I I am is a sensitive thin-skinned
snowflake neither of my family neither
are my business associates but when I
went out you may recall what happened
with Evans who's a black guy
and we reviewed properties
what I saw firsthand from Agents from
Land ladies there was one landlady that
literally said that they wouldn't do
business with Evans because he was scary
and when we pressed what do you mean
it's scary he's a black guy she's
obviously you know referring to the
color of your skin and I pressed her and
you know what she told me she said well
I don't do business with people that are
not English our only trust in English
you're an interesting English people but
you're not English yourself yeah
yeah and all the times I thought why are
they letting agents and the estate
agents why are they speaking differently
to me than they are to my wife is it
because she's a woman but then my
sister's on camera and ah it makes sense
now if you see some severe racism in the
property industry or if you see a
letting agent or an estate agent and
they discriminate against somebody
because the color of their skin then
you're gonna have to presumably report
it to who the property redress scheme if
you want to report it property redress
scheme and who are they they are a
government appointed official that makes
sure that tenants are looked after
there's no discrimination everything's
Fair disputes and guess what the
property reader scheme just put Vanessa
Warwick as their advisor and guess what
Vanessa Warwick runs property tribes
property tribes is what it's an online
Forum it's quite a cool form there's a
lot of landlords on there but that the
racism on property tribes is frankly
disgusting I have seen people on
property tribes landlords saying hey
quick question guys I'm renting out my
house last time an Indian person rented
it and I'm scared that might happen
again any tips I only want to rent it to
a white person
and I'm thinking how's this happening
why is this thread not being taken down
why is this not being deleted why is no
one standing up and saying that's wrong
that's discriminating against somebody
because of their ethnicity which is the
very definition of racism why are the
other landlords coming on and laughing
about it and saying haha me too me too
Vanessa Warwick who's the community
manager of property tribes came on and
commented you know what she said she
said well you don't have to tell them
what the reason for not moving them in
is so she's basically giving racist
landlords help and advice on how to be a
racist landlord without getting caught
so that it's legal that's who's in
charge right now of our country that's
the advisors on the property redress
scheme Vanessa Warwick you should be
ashamed of yourself property redress
scheme sort yourself out that is a
disgrace one of Vanessa Warwick's
landlords in the community recently
posted and said I'm having problems with
this company and put a link to the
company and Vanessa said I can tell by
the profile pictures of that company red
flags and I remember thinking red flags
from a profile picture I wonder I bet
they are ethnic minority click on it of
course I'm right and I'm not upset
because I just don't like Vanessa I'm
not upset just because my family
happened to be black I'm upset about
this because I think that it's wrong and
the only reason I decided to speak about
this now is because it was only about
two or three weeks ago when she was
announced to be an advisor on the
property redress scheme how how in 2022
a lot of people that are racist they
won't say I am racist it will just come
out in their actions and for full
transparency me and Vanessa have had
beef in the past she's used her platform
on property tribes to try and harass me
and defame me and bring me down for
years and the interesting thing is I
always thought why is she always trying
to bring me down because I don't know
her she's never come to any of my events
I've never had any dealings with her
ever I don't know her why does she hate
everything without so much and her
reason is she always says it's because
he teaches property to vulnerable people
and it really confused me because I
thought most of my students are you know
entrepreneurial critical thinkers
intelligent people sure they're my be
from a humble background I thought I
thought very very few of my students are
vulnerable until
Vanessa I listened to her definition of
vulnerable and Vanessa said herself that
vulnerable means
ex-offenders
drug dealers
and people on benefits
so that's why she thinks I'm dealing
with vulnerable people because fifty
percent of my audience are black and in
her mind black probably means for
ex-offenders drug addicts
benefits in fact she's taken some of my
students who are black and she's
tarnished them and said that they are
fraudsters they are wanted by the police
and they're like what some of them have
quit property altogether which is
exactly what she wants maybe Vanessa
feels the property is just for the elite
and for people in Guildford like she is
and for the white and when she sees
young black entrepreneurs rising up it
just pisses her off and we cannot ignore
this we must acknowledge it expose it
and rise above it in fact one of the
people that she said is wanted by the
police of course completely untrue who's
a young black man is now suing her in
the high court for defamation good on
you brother we cannot stand for this
anymore and I don't think she cares for
the vulnerable at all in fact when she
heard a story about a true vulnerable
person who had serious mental illnesses
and was making strange noises from a
property she thought it was hilarious he
was sectioned because of problems he had
she let out this evil laugh about how
funny it was that this poor tenant with
mental distress was making these strange
noises shame on you we cannot have
people like this in charge especially
when it comes to redress schemes so
property redress scheme sort this out
immediately and if you're watching this
video spread the message far and wide
because we cannot and we will not
tolerate racism or discrimination
anymore in this case